big news on the border front breaking in
just the last hour fox news has now
confirmed
that vice president kamala harrison
secretary of homeland security alejandra
mayorkas
will visit the u.s mexico border in el
paso texas
this week this would be just days before
former president donald trump and
republican lawmakers
are planning to visit the border it has
been 91 days
since president biden named harris as
the administration's border czar
republicans have heavily criticized her
for not visiting the border
since then though she has made other
trips to places like guatemala
joining us now is texas senator ted cruz
was her hand forced here senator she had
to get there before former president
trump
well of course it was i mean 91 days ago
she was named as borders are in charge
of the border crisis and
and she demonstrated strong leadership
by doing not a damn thing by going
nowhere near the border
by doing everything she could to hide
from the crisis
now frankly that's the same thing joe
biden is doing she's emulating the
president
in hiding from the crisis and so
suddenly president trump is going to the
border and they realize
oh crap we've got to do something but i
got to say even this announcement so she
announces that they're going to el paso
el paso is a lovely city it is a
beautiful place
in in texas it is not also it also
doesn't happen to be the locus of the
crisis you look at
the rio grande valley uh is andy and for
folks who aren't from texas let me give
you a sense so el paso is on
on the western tip of texas the rio
grande is
valley is almost on the southern tip of
texas it's
800 miles away to give you a sense of
just how far they are
chicago illinois is closer to washington
d.c
than el paso is to mcallen and so she's
going where the where the height of the
problem
isn't let me tell you what commonly
needs to do kamala you need to go to the
rio grande valley commonly you need to
go to mcallen
kamala you need to go to the donna tent
facility which is the tent city
your administration has built that is
massively over capacity that has
kids in cages you need to look at the
children in cages
that you and joe biden put there in a
way that is endangering their safety as
subjecting them
to abuse and sexual assault and there's
a reason john
she's not going to mcallen not going to
the rio grande valley because she
doesn't want the cameras to see
the joe biden cages with kids in cages i
mean there are a lot of people who say
that she didn't want to go to the border
and have that photograph
or that video to be replayed again and
again and again but i mean just
in in all fairness the el paso sector is
where
uh the house minority leader kevin
mccarthy and a lot of republicans went
they also went to the arizona
uh sort of the new mexico sectors as
well
so republicans have been there too to
that area of texas oh sure ed listen
i've been to el paso many many times el
paso is
is a wonderful thriving border community
it's a very important community
and there are certainly real problems
with illegal immigration
in el paso but there's a reason
she doesn't want the tv cameras to show
hundreds upon hundreds and thousands
upon thousands of children
lying side by side by side you remember
a couple of months ago when i took
19 senators down to the border and we
went to that donna tent facility that
that tent facility
was built to hold a thousand people with
covid restrictions its capacity was 250
the day we were there there were over 4
200 people packed in that facility with
a 10
covet positivity rate kamala harris
needs to look in the eyes of the
children who are suffering because of
joe biden's failed immigration policies
and when she looks in the eyes and
realizes this isn't working
that's when they need to end catch and
release and they need to reinstate the
remain in mexico
international agreement that had solved
this problem
until joe biden and kamala harris
screwed it up senator this is jillian
turner along with john here in the d.c
bureau i'm curious to hear from you
despite everything you just laid out the
criticism of
you know the fact that this is coming
late the criticism that she's going to
el paso
rather than the rio grande are you happy
she's making this trip it's something
that you and your colleagues have been
calling for for months
one of your colleagues uh senator cotton
just tweeted out
reaction to the news he says complete
mistake
kamal harris will find some way to make
the crisis worse so it sounds like now
she's finally doing what you guys want
her to do
but there's still a lot of unhappiness
oh listen
sure i'm glad she's going to the border
she doesn't have any solutions
you ought to pause and ask i mean she's
gotten a lot of grief
over 91 days for not going to the border
any rational person would say well gosh
if you're named in charge of the border
jillian tomorrow if the president called
and said
jillian is in charge of the border and
the crisis there
i'm willing to bet within what 24 48
maybe 72 hours you'd get on a plane and
fly down to the border you'd say all
right if i'm in charge of this thing let
me see what's going on
well we'd have a lot of problems senator
if i was tasked with managing the border
tomorrow
but i will say it's not
just your republican colleagues that
have been unhappy with this
delay a lot of americans who live along
the border region that we've been
talking to the last month at fox news
say
they need help they need her eyes on the
ground or the president's eyes on the
ground to understand in addition to the
northern triangles
underlying problems americans underlying
problems
well i think that's exactly right and
we're seeing increased crime
increased violence increased drugs
we're seeing this is a humanitarian
disaster and it's a public health
disaster it's a national security
disaster and the thing that's important
to understand is this is man-made
the joe biden and kamala harris caused
this
when they reinstated the failed policy
of catch and release
and when they ended remain in mexico so
remain in mexico was an international
agreement
that president trump had negotiated with
mexico where mexico agreed that anyone
who crossed illegally into mexico
they would stay there in mexico while
their u.s
asylum case proceeded and it ended up
working
incredibly well last year
in the year 2020 we had the lowest rate
of illegal immigration in
45 years it was incredibly successful
when joe biden and kamala harris tore
that international agreement to shreds
we went from the lowest rate of illegal
immigration in 45 years to today
the highest rate in over 20 years
we've already had a half million people
come in illegally and we're on pace
for more than two million people in the
first year
of the biden harris administration it's
their mistakes that are causing this
and they need to fix it look the people
of texas are on the front lines
parent paying the price and and
the reason kamala waited 91 days to go
to the border is she knew if she went
tv cameras would come and they would
document the human
misery the chaos and disaster that
that biden and harris are producing and
they don't have any answers
because they've given the radical left a
promise
that they will not enforce the laws they
will not deport people
they will have open borders and they're
causing this suffering right now
senator we should point out that former
president trump has just weighed in in a
statement saying quote after months of
ignoring the crisis
at the southern border it is great that
we got kamala harris to finally go and
see the tremendous destruction and debt
that they've created a direct result of
biden ending
by very tough but fair border policies
harris and biden were given the
strongest border in american history
and now it is by far the worst in
american history if governor abbott and
i were not
going to the border next week she would
have
never gone you don't have any
expectation do you that the vice
president will go visit the el paso
sector and say
oh my goodness what we're doing isn't
working we need to do something
completely different
no to the contrary i think what she's
going to say is we need to turn the
revolving door
even faster that as soon as we apprehend
someone illegally we need to let him go
even more quickly you know the the the
biden harris administration is trying to
ship
illegal immigrants all over the country
and it's it's really stunning you go
down to the border
and and you see this this caravan of
people it's not even that border patrol
agents are apprehending them they go
seek out the border patrol agents they
turn themselves in
because the biden harris administration
right now
is the last mile of the human
trafficking and human smuggling network
because the cartels
get them just over the river and then
they find
find the administration because they'll
ship them to wherever they want to go
and and and
i think kamala's only solution to that
is less process
even faster and and the result is is
tragically going to be
even more illegal immigration the only
answer
is to enforce the laws and and to move
back to what we know was working just a
few months ago the remain in mexico
policy
but but their radical politics won't let
them do that senator
we know that you disagree with the
binding administration's border policy
at the southern border writ large we
know that you're not happy with the
situation on the ground
inside of texas or on the other side of
the border in mexico but given
reality as it is right now today what is
the best possible messaging
you could see the vice president deliver
once she's over there is it along the
lines of what she said last month when
she said
she told the northern triangle migrants
to not come to the u.s or is it
something else
those were empty words when when she
said that in in guatemala and in fact
you look the president of guatemala
openly openly pointed out that biden
harris their message to everyone
was coming legally the borders are open
and that's what that's why you're seeing
illegal immigrants crossing
wearing joe biden t-shirts because the
message has come out
that if you get here you get to cross
over illegally
and they're causing this and and look
they
think it is compassionate sorry to
interrupt you but if you had the chance
to determine
or to advise the vice president on what
to say on this trip what is the message
here
right here's what kamala harris should
say
we are reversing three decisions that
joe biden and i made
in the first week of the administration
joe biden halted construction of the
border wall
we're resuming construction of the
border wall joe biden reinstated the
failed policy of catch and release we're
ending catch and release so if you get
apprehended we're not just going to let
you go and let you stay in america
and number three joe biden ended the
remaining mexico policy that has proven
to be an enormous mistake
we recognize it was a mistake and so
we're reinstating the remain in mexico
policy
which produced the lowest rate of
illegal immigration in 45 years that's
what she should
say the chances that she will say that
are
zero because biden and harris
have handed control of their immigration
agenda over to the radical left
who don't want the laws enforced they
want open borders they support open
borders
and until joe and kamala are willing to
change their policies this chaos this
crisis will keep getting worse and worse
there'll be more violence there'll be
more murders more cartels
and more drugs killing americans across
this country
senator there's a lot of pressure on the
white house right now too from
progressives to racine title 42 which
was enacted in may of 2020
which has resulted in 62 percent of the
people that cross the border
every month including more than 100 000
in the month of may
to be sent back over the border if if
this administration
were to rescind title 42 what do you
think would happen
the problem would get even worse title
42 at least during a pandemic gave you
the ability to exclude some adults
and and early on uh within the first
weeks biden and harris put a big
exception to title 42 that basically
said
if you have a kid with you you can stay
and what we started seeing
and and the numbers had been exploding
as we started seeing these single adult
males would show up with a kid and by
the way when you dna test the kids
a very significant percentage of the
kids are not related to those adult
males the cartels are literally
renting kids to illegal immigrants and
these kids are being
horribly abused that's the result of
biden harris's policies and that's
something that we've covered but
if 62 percent of all of the border
encounters
uh during the month of may and there was
like 190 000 of those
right uh were sent back over the border
if
if you were to rescind title 42 do you
expect that
there would be a tidal wave of people
who would try to get across the border
i think that's exactly right because
that takes catch and release and
it puts it on steroids it makes then the
policy of the biden-harris
administration
essentially whoever comes gets released
and let me tell you how backwards their
policy is
so they're releasing hundreds of
thousands of illegal aliens into this
country
many of them without covid test many of
them from facilities where covet is
about 10 percent positivity
at the same time joe biden just
reinstituted the ban
on legal immigration on folks crossing
the ports of entry in texas to come
to come to texas say to go shopping or
to visit friends or family people are
coming legally
they've shut that down they say that's
non-essential
i got to say it's exactly backwards they
ought to open those ports of entry
to legal immigrants and they ought to
stop
uh releasing and and encouraging
illegal immigration biden harris get
that totally backwards
senator thanks for jumping in on short
notice really appreciated again the big
news that
kamala harris the vice president and
alejandro mayorkas
the secretary of homeland security will
be visiting the border
in the el paso sector looks like friday
senator thanks for joining us appreciate
it